[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue à l'entretien de
France 24 nous sommes en direct de
Taipei aujourd'hui notre invité est le
ministre taïwanais des Affaires
étrangères José fou bonjour bonjour
comment allez-vous merci beaucoup de
nous recevoir à votre ministère au cœur
de la capitale taïwanais Monsieur le
Ministre on constate qu'il y a une
montée des tensions forte autour de
Taïwan c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
à cause de la Chine question très simple
monsieur le ministre pourquoi Taïwan
pourquoi vous et pourquoi maintenant
vous savez très important parce qu'elle
est dans un emplacement très stratégique
sur la première chaîne d'île le Japon
Nord les Philippines au sud
la Chine veut conquérir Taïwan et parce
que la Chine veut étendre son emprise
sur le
doit être conquise ce régime autoritaire
de Pékin c'est concentré sur Time en
pensant que la communauté internationale
pourrait se focaliser
l'expansionnisme de la Chine ailleurs
de garrythorique de la part du
gouvernement chinois
maintenant
si vous regardez l'activité à plus long
terme de l'activité chinoise contre
Thaïlande ça a commencé il y a trois
quatre ans
c'est là qu'ils ont fait monter la
pression sur Taïwan et puis au début de
2019 le président
a fait un discours sur Taïwan c'était le
2 janvier et là il a défini la position
de la machine sur Taïwan il a proclamé
que le Taïwan doit accepter la position
d'une seule Chine doit accepter le
schéma de un pays avec deux systèmes et
la Chine se réserve le droit d'avoir
recours à la force contre Taïwan et à
partir de là on a vu de plus en plus de
pression de la part de la Chine
maintenant si on regarde leur activité
militaire auteur de Taïwan on s'aperçoit
qu'ils sont intervenir de plus en plus
d'avions dans notre zone
d'identification de défense aérienne et
donc il y a beaucoup de précieux
militaires sur Taïwan et puis en plus
ils ont lancé une grande campagne de
désinformation
psychologique de la coercition
économique et j'en passe cela ne cause
des problèmes
[Musique]
au début d'août ils ont pris le prétexte
de la visite de la présidente Pelosi
pour lancer de grandes manœuvres
militaires contre Taïwan
plus ils ont lancé 11 missiles dans les
eaux proches et fait participer de
nombreux navires et avions à des
exercices aériens et maritimes
ils ont aussi lancé de nombreuses
cyberattaques d'ailleurs le réseau notre
ministère a été incapacité pendant un
certain temps et puis il y a une grande
campagne de désinformation de la
coercition économique etc donc au total
il semble pratiquer des jeux de guerre
pour préparer l'invasion de Taïwan
monsieur le ministre Ford nez moi vous
avez prononcé le mot invasion
est-ce une crainte côté taiwanais
long moyen court terme est-ce que c'est
quelque chose qui pourrait avoir lieu
craignez-vous une invasion chinoise très
très occupée par une éventuelle invasion
par la Chine le gouvernement chinois
continue d'évoquer l'usage de la force
sur Taïwan si vous écoutez les
dirigeants de haut niveau du Parti
communiste chinois
s'exprimant au sein d'organisation
internationale ils utilisent une
résolution des Nations Unies qui précise
que Taïwan est une question intérieure
chinoise ainsi aucun autre pays ne peut
intervenir dans la politique intérieure
chinoise y compris l'usage de la force
par la Chine contre Taïwan et Sims
tire partie de tout cela pour légitimer
l'usage de la force contre Taïwan pour
nous c'est très préoccupant car la Chine
semble vouloir mobiliser toutes sortes
de paramètres pour préparer le terrain
du
par la Russie a-t-elle du point de vue
taïwanais changer la perception d'une
éventuelle invasion y a-t-il eu un
changement de paradigme
la guerre a été suivie en direct par les
Taïwanais ils ont vu à la télé
les horreurs de la guerre et nous avons
réalisé que si la Russie pouvait faire
ça aux Ukrainiens
les Chinois pourraient faire la même
chose
[Musique]
la guerre doit arriver à Taïwan nous
devons y être prêt
donc
juste après le début de la guerre en
Ukraine les Taïwanais ont ressenti de
manière plus aiguë l'urgence de la
situation
donc il semble résolu à de Taïwan et en
même temps le gouvernement se prépare à
une crise éventuelle
nous voulons être prêt pour une invasion
chinoise nous voulons assurer la forme
de militaires avoir davantage d'armes
sur tous les armes asymétriques
nous voulons travailler avec les
États-Unis et les pays qui ont les mêmes
idées pour être prêt à une éventuelle
invasion
experts affirment que cela conduirait à
une guerre bien plus large du point de
vue des conséquences internationales que
la guerre en Ukraine peut-être même à la
troisième guerre mondiale avec pour
point de départ
est-ce que vous préparez à cela est-ce
qu'on s'y prépare bien sûr toute guerre
toute guerre est une catastrophe pour
les populations
mais vous êtes prêts nous ne voulons pas
la guerre mais si la Chine doit nous
attaquer
nous devons être prêt
pour nous nous préparons à une invasion
éventuelle
parlons des répercussions oui la
percussion serait très grave
quelques instants s'il vous plaît pour
expliquer
d'abord au niveau économique
on parle beaucoup des semi-conducteurs
vous savez que Taïwan produit 62% de
l'ensemble des
semi-conducteurs maintenant si on
regarde les semi-conducteurs de haut
niveau Taiwan en produit
92% de la production mondiale
donc suite
et la chaîne d'approvisionnement des
semi-conducteurs est impacté c'est le
reste du monde qui ressentira ces
atteintes vous vous souviendrez sûrement
du début des covid il y a une pénurie de
semis conducteurs
on peut les constructeurs automobiles la
France produit beaucoup d'automobiles et
ça a beaucoup affecté ce constructeur
imaginez que les semi-conducteurs de
haut niveau de Taïwan que cette chaîne
d'approvisionnement soit bouleversée je
saurai de la percussions épouvantable
sur l'économie mondiale
je voudrais prendre quelques instants
pour vous parler de la situation
géopolitique beaucoup de gens parlent de
Taïwan en disant la Chine veut Taïwan je
suis ambition ne s'arrête pas là
les activités militaires chinoises dans
la mer orientale ont rendu nos amis
japonais très nerveux
parce qu'il y avait une zone qui était
administrée par les Japonais et
désormais les Chinois envoient tous les
jours des navires militaires dans cette
région pratiquement tous les jours ils
vont chasser les pêcheurs japonais dans
cette mer de Chine du Sud
mais pas seulement là
Washington en 2015 il avait promis de ne
pas militariser cette région mais la
Chine a transformé des îlots en base
massive
pleinement
et puis sont aussi armés des centaines
de bateaux de pêche
transformée en milice pour compléter
leur force navale c'est ça l'ambition de
la Chine en maire de Chine du Sud c'est
la réunification dans la bouche de chez
King
réification qu'est-ce que cela signifie
quand il dit signification ça veut dire
qu'il va conquérir Taïwan par des moyens
pacifiques ou par la force
c'est ça qui parlait mais il y a quelque
chose qui manque la réalité
tu n'as jamais été gouverné par la Chine
Taïwan ce gouverne elle-même vous êtes à
Taïwan vous savez que nous avons
président élu publiquement la
démocratiquement nous avons aussi un
parlement et également élu publiquement
ministère des Affaires étrangères qui
émet des visas des passeports bien sûr
monsieur le ministre mais ne pensez-vous
pas également que la voix de
souveraineté c'est aussi celle de
l'indépendance qu'en pensez-vous la
réalité et que nous n'appartenons pas à
un autre pays ni d'ailleurs la Chine
nous sommes une démocratie qui se
gouvernait même et ça c'est fondamental
il est agonie sont très heureux de notre
mode de vie démocratique toute forme
d'unification soit CAPI nous impose son
modèle soit par la force qui ne tient
pas compte de la volonté des taïwanais
est une sorte d'invasion
cette invasion cette utilisation de la
force irait contre le principe le plus
fondamental des Nations Unies
et donc nos alliés des autres
démocraties doivent s'unir pour
persuader la Chine de pas utiliser la
force contre-attaïwan
la Chine va peut s'arrêter à la mère de
Chine du Nord ou du Sud ils vont
probablement s'aventurer à l'intérieur
du Pacifique
ils ont effectué des exercices et de
trois dernières années au-delà de la
première chaîne d'îles
très profondément dans le Pacifique en
juin ils ont signé un accord de sécurité
avec les îles Salomon qui sont très loin
de la Chine et très près de l'Australie
la chimie veut aussi enfiler son collier
de perles dans l'océan Indien
au Pakistan au Bangladesh et jusqu'à
Djibouti
ils veulent renforcer leur force navale
c'est ça l'ambition chinoise donc si
Taïwan tombe sous les coups de la Chine
vous pourrez réfléchir au répercussions
pour le reste du monde je crois que le
monde entier les démocraties en
particulier doivent réfléchir à ces
éventualités nous devons travailler
ensemble pour endiguer une expansion
supplémentaire de l'autoritarisme merci
monsieur le ministre pour cette
entretien merci pour ces propos très
forts merci de nous accueillir dans
votre ministère c'est la fin de
l'entretien France 24 depuis Taipei
merci d'être avec nous à bientôt
[Musique]
ouvrez les fenêtres de la météo avec
Technal
Technal fenêtre porte véranda en
aluminium